what do you think bitcoin's price goes
to this year in 2021 well
i'll give you that but i think that it's
going to be a million dollars a coin
okay not this year necessarily maybe not
this cycle but i think pretty soon it
will be um
i think that
uh if if we get another momentum in the
market it's just my opinion and you know
these things they trade with momentum
you know even like mstr stock it trades
with momentum if we get an upward
momentum and let's say that there's
continues to be this high inflation
print
you know
there's no ceiling to where it could go
but i would say you know 75
i think it'll at least be at 75.
so new all-time high this year yeah and
then you think that at some point the
next couple years a million dollars i
think probably mid next year i think
that it it will get it will get harder
uh
just the growth in the economy i think
will be harder on stuff and i do think
bitcoin and we may disagree on this i do
think bitcoin at least from what i've
seen
tends to trade like a commodity from
what i've seen
um
and i've been a little disappointed with
it the last couple weeks at how uh you
know how
how much it traded even with the market
but i guess that's you know that's pr
it's probably nothing compared to what
it used to be right
it ha it happens it tends to be a
non-correlated asset but there are
periods where it gets high correlation
and a lot of it's the macro stuff where
people just start saying hey there's a
risk asset or whatever and also it used
to be a much different audience that
held bitcoin as you get into now more
financially savvy folks with it then
you're gonna have them trade it like
it's another stock or another commodity
in their portfolio versus historically
those people who they didn't care about
the financials and again this is out of
my circle of competency so i don't
really know it but you know you ask so
that's what i think what are you
giggling about nothing
i think we're going over 100 this year
you think we're going over 100k yeah
yeah what what is the math behind that
yeah young wizard will clemente
[Laughter]
you know what else it just went over
it was one over 5000 likes so get your
checkbook out if it goes over if it goes
over
a hundred thousand i'll come back and
give more money away there we go you
might be back in like a couple of weeks
what uh is this i guess i gotta buy more
babies it's going towards the end of the
year like a make a break like is this
make a break for bitcoin or
say it sits at 40 for the rest of the
year bitcoin could drop to three
thousand dollars and i would literally
sell the shirt off your back to get more
money to go buy it that's the other
thing too is like when when bill was
talking earlier about if you're
comfortable losing the amount of money
the 95 or whatever at the end of the day
uh it's never gonna go to zero because
there's so many there's so many people
who have such a strong conviction that
would never sell right like you're never
gonna sell it so it's not it's never
gonna you're lowering that risk reward
profile right on the wrist side and then
if it dips down to that number wherever
it ends up being like you would just
aggressively buy as much as you could
knowing that there's only ever going to
be 21 million the demand is still super
strong if bitcoin dropped at 3 000
michael saylor and president buchelli
would have to fight me to see who could
buy the bitcoin at 3k okay right like
so would everybody else what about like
18 000
like why 3 000 would you just whatever
whatever
it dropped to 30 000. i bought a bunch
more right and it wasn't because i was
like oh any other reason than like i
just periodically buy more as i make
more money uh which keeps them like 95
percent but also uh
when it dips i have such a long-term
conviction like the other piece of this
too is like there's people who trade it
right so they want to buy it today
they're going to sell tomorrow buy it
today they're going to sell it in a week
or whatever that's not me yeah i
literally just say as i buy it i don't
have a number in my head okay now i got
more now i got more and i just say look
i'm going to hand to my grandkids and i
think that psychologically like when i
decided that so what does your bride
think about you owning 95 percent she
sold the reason why there's five percent
uh not in bitcoin it's worked out so far
because that was our that was our
agreement was uh there had to be a
certain amount of money that was in the
bank account where it was like all right
we're like we're good uh for a period of
time and then you could do you know
whatever you want and i talked to her
about it but i think uh
there's been two times where
it was dropping aggressively and i had
like bought like uh i told story of uh
in march 2020 it went from like eight
thousand to four thousand a single day
or like thirty eight hundred and that
morning i wrote a piece and published it
like i took the time out of my day wrote
a piece and said we're in a liquidity
crisis asset prices are selling off
they're likely to sell off more so i
went from eight to six i bought a bunch
then went from six to like 5 500 i
bought you know uh a little bit more and
then i think it like got down to like 4
800 and i remember saying to myself like
am i gonna watch this go to zero like i
was literally sitting on the couch like
staring off in space and for whatever
you know it's coming like whatever just
psychologically like it just sucks and
she looked at me she's like what's wrong
and i was like bitcoin might go to zero
like i might just like watch this blow
up and she said to me she was like what
are you doing
buy more she's like you're like like if
it's going down like just like go down
with the ship yeah and so i you know uh
very reluctantly bought a little bit
more and i remember saying to myself
like there's almost this beauty in not
being involved in it every day because
she was just like
i don't think she computed like the
price of drop 50 percent and all this
stuff she's just like what do you
believe do you ever have days where you
don't check the price
i rarely check the price actually good
for you uh the only times i check the
price are uh one people like to tweet it
at me so i happen to see it then uh or
two is uh when i read like a news
article and what i'm very interested in
now is like when china reiterated this
ban last week um
bitcoin's only down like four five
percent i would have thought if you told
me hey they're gonna do it again like
all right here we go down you know 10 12
percent and so it looks like the mark is
becoming less sensitive to certain
narratives that's great it's bullish
yeah but if you know certain people went
out and tweeted today in the united
states and said something you know they
could tank it 10-15 percent you know
overnight so you just kind of pay
attention to it and try to figure it out
there i check the price all the time
and it's a problem because even if it
goes up i'm not going to sell any so
it's just like i'm just making myself
worried and then when it goes that's a
deal yeah
so i feel like that'll wear off after
time but it's still fun yeah it's still
fun what's up guys bang bang thanks so
much for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you ten dollars in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]